>> Hello, everyone.
Welcome to Authors at Google.
We're going to have a talk by Serge Michel
and Paolo Woods on their book, “China Safari.”
I started reading about this topic about a
year and a half ago, and got very interested.
So when the topic came up, I jumped at the
chance to present -- to host -- them.
I think everyone's going to find it very fascinating
to hear about how these two very important
parts of the world are coming together in
a way that's going to have a big impact on
both of their economies and on the rest of
the world.
If you've got your computer and you're not
on call, please turn it off.
And please welcome our speakers.
Thank you very much for coming.
>> [Clapping].
Serge Michel: Hello.
So do you hear as well? Yeah?
So my name is Serge Michel, and I'm a writer
from Switzerland working mostly for European
newspapers and magazines.
I've been based in Zurich, in Tehran, in Belgrade,
and in Dakar.
And now, I'm back home in Geneva.
And I'm also the founder of the Bondy Blog,
which is in the volatile suburbs of Paris,
and it's a 2.0 Web Project that employs about
a hundred young immigrants in France.
It has been ten years that I work with Paolo,
and we've produced three books together, which
is the last one.
And now we are working on a new one about
Iran.
We've been there the whole month of June.
Paolo Woods: Hello, my name is Paolo Woods.
I'm the son of a Dutch mother and a Canadian
father.
I was brought up in Italy.
I presently live in Paris.
And I'm a photographer.
I've been a photographer since I was 17.
And in the last ten years, I've been working
on long-term projects, mainly with Serge,
which are stories that have something to do
with the news but is not hard news.
We don't work directly for tomorrow's newspaper.
We work for stories that try to look into
depth in subjects that we think are necessary.
The first two books we did before this one
-- the first one was called "A Crude World.”
And it's a story about oil through the whole
world for 12 different countries and four
different continents.
And to see, we investigated they've actually
been an oil producing country -- is a blessing
or is a curse for its own people.
And the second one was a long investigation
into two wars of George Bush in Afghanistan
and in Iraq, where we worked for a very long
time both times.
So then, we have this project.
And then, we are also together publishers
of a small -- we have a small publishing company
together with a third colleague called Claude
Baechtold, and we produce small travel guidebooks
and images to expected destinations like this
one.
So, it's guidebooks just composed of images.
This one was to Afghanistan.
Serge Michel: So why did we do the book called
China Safari?
When I was correspondent in West Africa for
Le Monde, I felt that there was a new phenomenon
taking place, one that would change the face
of Africa.
Half a million Chinese had come to Africa,
not as missionaries, not as aid workers, but
for the raw materials they need to fuel their
amazing growth.
And we were sinners.
We often see only misery, genocide, wars,
disease, and drugs in Africa.
But the Chinese -- they are going there, to
some of the poorest and the most dangerous
places in the world, with the real sense of
21st century adventure.
And they're investing there, and sometimes,
making a fortune.
So they consider Africa actually as an opportunity
while we westerners we often see it as with
empathy as a place for handout.
So we felt that it was a very important story
that was not getting enough attention.
The story is not only about China and Africa;
it concerns actually the whole world.
This is a bit the accomplishment of globalization.
China is using Africa as a trampoline to become
the first world power.
Paolo Woods: So how did we do this story?
This is the kind of story that cannot anymore
be financed by a magazine or a newspaper.
No newspaper will send you today for over
two years to 12 African countries and twice
to China on assignment.
And we wanted very much not to do a story
sitting in an office looking at statistics
and numbers, but we wanted to do on-ground
reporting like we always did.
We wanted actually to meet these Chinese,
go into Africa, and for the 21st century adventure
for them for looking for a new place for the
development for themselves.
So we started in North Africa and southern
Africa, in the west and in the east, and tried
to cover all the different aspects.
In each country, tried to analyze why the
Chinese were there, what were they doing there,
what were the specific issues in each country.
Serge Michel: The man under the umbrella is
called Jacob Wood.
And -- I'm sorry to say it here -- but, before
we interviewed him in Lagos, Nigeria, in April
2007, he did not exist on Google.
But he ought to, because this man is one of
the biggest Chinese entrepreneurs in Nigeria.
He's the owner of about 15 factories there,
and he's an adviser to the president, who's
offering him a constant police escort.
He stands here in front of 544 villas that
his company has built in six months for the
American oil company, Chevron.
Paolo Woods: And here we are in a steel factory
also in Nigeria, owned by a friend of Jacob
Wood we just saw.
And what you see here is a Chinese supervisor
and a Nigerian worker in a not a very friendly
pose.
What you might notice as well is, that the
Chinese supervisor is wearing protective shoes,
while the Nigerian worker is just wearing
flip-flops.
Serge Michel: So still, the relationship -- the
working relationship -- can be tough, but
there is also a real proximity.
Look at this supervisor here teaching a Nigerian
worker in the heat of the same steel factory.
If he was a westerner, he would just sit in
the office with air conditioning and checking
the production figures on the computer, and
he would also get 20 times more money.
Paolo Woods: This is another factory.
This is a biscuit factory -- Nabisco biscuit
factory.
And it's interesting because, this factory
produces about seventy tons of biscuits each
day which cover just one percent of the demand
in Nigeria.
But this biscuit factory had been previously
owned by British, by Indians, by Nigerians,
and it always went bankrupt.
And when the Chinese took it over with their
very strong work ethic, they're making it
work in one of the countries where businesses,
which is not oil, have a hard time flourishing
-- you know that Nigeria is Africa's biggest
oil producer -- and this company is now running
24/7 with two shifts a day -- two 12-hour
shifts a day -- employing a lot of local workforce.
So this engineer is explaining to the workers
some of the workings of the factory.
Serge Michel: There is a club in Lagos for
Chinese entrepreneurs with about 200 members.
And some of them are in their early 20's and
but all very successful.
Here is their monthly meeting in the restaurant.
It's an expensive one.
And the African waiters are wearing traditional
Chinese costumes directly imported.
Paolo Woods: This is the wife of Mr. Wood,
the man we saw in the very first photograph
under the umbrella -- or I should probably
better say, one of the wives of Mr. Wood -- because,
Mr. Wood has adopted a lot of local customs,
so he has become polygamous as well as also
learning the local language and all that.
So this wife is called Amy Wood, and she is
shown here in one of the restaurants she runs.
This is a five-story restaurant, 1,500 seats
in the center of Lagos.
And in this particular photo, she is throwing
a banquet for the president of the Nigerian
senate, who's celebrating here his 70th birthday
with 300 guests.
Serge Michel: Let's go now to Congo.
This picture, which is also the cover of the
book -- it's a dam under construction and
a dam for which the western aid agencies -- the
IMF, the World Bank -- constantly refused
to finance because of the lack of transparency,
the lack of good governance, the lack of democracy,
the lack of stability in the country.
The Chinese were not bothered by these shortcomings,
and they not only financed the dam, but they
also are building it.
They sent 400 workers from China to Congo
for that project, and they hired about a thousand
Congolese workers.
And to make that sure they know who's who,
they have asked the Chinese supervisors to
have yellow helmets and the Africans to have
blue helmets.
Paolo Woods: This dam, when completed, will
double Congo's electricity output.
Which is something which is badly needed if
you think that Congo -- the capital, Brazzaville
-- only has three hours of electricity a
day.
It might be very difficult to operate a company
like Google in a place that only has three
hours of electricity each day.
So you see that infrastructures, at times,
come before the necessity of good governance,
democracy, in any case, in the Chinese vision.
Serge Michel: Ministers in Africa have the
reputation of not doing many things for their
own people, and that is often the case.
But China now helps African governments to
achieve more and to get so easily reelected.
Alphonse Nsilou here -- you see him -- is
the housing and construction minister in Congo.
And Chinese have made his life very easy.
He's also an architect, and he can sketch
whatever he likes -- they will build it, just
in time for the election.
And the Chinese will later get repaid by Congolese
oil.
Paolo Woods: So here you can see behind is
people here.
Some of these villas that minister Nsilou
has designed, which are being constructed
by the Chinese company.
And these are going to be villas for middle-class
Congolese families.
The two Chinese here are photographing this
project with their Congolese translator, and
these images will then be used back home to
raise more capital for investment in Africa.
Serge Michel: One of the problems in the working
sites in Africa with the Chinese is that they
don't share any common language, so the only
way to communicate is by gestures and not
always very friendly ones.
Paolo Woods: And this, you could say, is a
photograph speaking about the birth of the
union.
These are Congolese workers working on a project
run by Chinese.
And they're paid roughly four dollars a day.
About half of that goes away in transport
to get to worksite and in the lunch -- the
lunch is not offered like it is here, in this
case.
And so they're left only with two dollars,
and they don't have a contract.
They're not insured.
They claim to get regularly beaten by their
Chinese bosses.
And when -- if they're injured, they get fired
immediately.
So there is a very strong, anti-Chinese sentiment
growing in the lower sections of the population.
Serge Michel: But still, the Chinese language
and Chinese themselves remain very attractive.
And here, we are in the high school at Brazzaville,
with students passing their exams in Chinese
language.
These classes had to be doubled every year,
because more and more students in Congo want
to learn Chinese.
And one of the reasons for that is that if
they learn English, they will not -- the chance
to get an American visa is very low.
And if they learn French -- well, they speak
some French basically, but not very well -- they
will also never get a French visa.
But there are more and more visas for them
in China, and you have a growing diaspora
-- African diaspora -- in cities like Canton
and in Beijing.
Paolo Woods: Here we're on the beach of Pointe-Noire
in Congo.
And this is some of the members of the family
Ye.
The lady you see standing next to the small
girl is called Jessica Ye, and she arrived
in 2001 to Congo penniless from China.
She was working as a translator on a Chinese
construction site.
She had learned some French.
And eight years on, she today is at the head
of a small empire that spans from logging
concessions in the Congo forest till cement
import, from prostitution to a factory producing
aluminum window frames.
And in the years, she has brought eighty members
of her family to Congo, of which you will
see some of them here.
Serge Michel: And here we witnessed the very
animated discussion between Phillip -- who
is Jessica's brother -- and the former owner
of her restaurant that Phillip has just bought.
The Congolese man came to claim the money
for the restaurant and the Chinese man was
trying to delay the payment.
Paolo Woods: This is the husband of Jessica,
Mr. Zhang, and he is photographed here in
one of his houses in Pointe-Noire.
This house used to be the residence of the
German counsel and now, it is one of his properties
there.
He is at the head of the family's logging
business.
Each member of the family is given one business
to supervise, and he is the one taking care
of the whole logging business.
He used to be a journalist for the Chinese
news agency, but now has gone into the private
and is working on that.
Serge Michel: And the Ye family has managed
to get the largest concession in Congo, which
consists of 800,000 hectares in the Congo
Basin Forest.
And you know, the Congolese forest is the
second largest rain forest in the world after
the Amazon.
And to our astonishment, actually part of
the family's concession is right in the middle
of the national park.
So we went together with Mr. Zhang to that
controversial concession.
It was an eight-hour jeep ride from Pointe-Noire.
Paolo Woods: And you here see one of these
trees falling.
These trees take about 100 years to grow,
and about five minutes to be cut down.
And this particular tree is supposed to be
in a protected species.
So we were quite taken aback by the fact that
this logging concession was in a national
forest.
And, especially, because we had interviewed
for a couple of days earlier, the Minister
of Forestry of Congo.
For someone who is very vocal about the fact
that he's there to protect the forest -- "It's
a big asset for Congo," and he has written
books about it.
And so, we were pretty encouraged by this
man's engagement to protect his country.
And so, we spoke with Mr. Zhang -- the man
who runs the timber activity -- about how,
you know, he had been able to get this logging
concession in the national forest since the
minister is so strong about it.
And, you know, he smiled to us with a smirk
and said, "You know, the minister is one of
the shareholders of my company."
Serge Michel: And one of the problems of this
logging activity in the Congo forest is that
the workers are not fed by the Chinese bus.
And there is no supermarket, no village around.
It's really deep into the forest.
So, the only way to survive is to hunt for
animals.
So the damage they exert on the environment
is double.
During the day, they cut trees; and during
the night, they kill animals.
This is a brew diker, which is not a species
very protected, but if they cross the path
of a gorilla, they wouldn't refrain themselves
and shoot.
Paolo Woods: Here's another case.
Another worker showing off his night catch
which then will become his lunch.
Serge Michel: So the law in Congo says that
80 percent of the wood must be processed there
in Congo, but the reality is more close to
ten to 15 percent.
So the Chinese, the Ye family has managed
to revive a wood factory where they do plywood
for export and it comes actually to America.
But this represents very small fraction of
their production there.
Paolo Woods: Most of it, as you see here is
waiting at harbor for the boats that will
bring it to China, where it then will be worked
on and then will be exported around the world.
This table here, for example, might be done
with African wood, then worked in China.
What we have to understand today is that,
when we see on something written, "Made in
China", more and more that actually means,
"Extracted in Africa."
Serge Michel: So we see here, Phillip -- he
was just on the picture before on the logs
in the harbor of Pointe-Noire.
We see him now in a different setting.
He's here in his hometown in China called
Wenzhou, south of Shanghai.
And he's on the top of his building for holidays.
He's going to spend three weeks there.
And you know, it's often said that Chinese
have no right to go back after they emigrate.
The only way to come back is to be successful.
So he went back to China with a lot of money,
with a good car, with a very high lifestyle
to just show off and spend his Afro dollars,
we could call them.
Paolo Woods: And he does party a lot.
He parties hard with his friend.
This is in a karaoke bar, and the friend is
one of the responsibles of the local policemen.
But he just doesn't -- not only parties -- he's
also always doing business.
So right here, what he's doing -- he's prospecting
for the next things he's going to develop
in Africa.
He has bought a cigarette factory, which he's
going to bring to Congo, and he's also starting
a business where he's importing spare car
parts to Congo.
Serge Michel: So while we were in China, we
also wanted to see who are the simple workers
who get ready to leave to Africa.
So we went to Sichuan Province, and we found
this man called Peng Shu Lin.
It was actually the very day of his departure
to Nigeria for three years.
You see on his bed, the small bag is the only
luggage he will take with him to Africa.
And he's here in China.
He was earning about a hundred dollars a month
for being a specialized worker in plastic
molding.
For the very same job in Africa, he will get
five hundred dollars.
And this man has never left his province,
has never taken the plane, has never seen
a black man.
And he's leaving tonight to Nigeria for three
years.
All his objective is to save money there,
and then come back to China with 15 or $20,000
and open his own small business.
Paolo Woods: And now we are in the north of
Africa, in Nigeria.
This is suburbs of Abuja, the capital.
And this used to be a nomad path, as you still
see some go through, but behind them there
spurt up like mushrooms, housing developments
built by a Chinese company to relieve Algeria
of the very big housing crisis they have.
Serge Michel: Algeria has gone through a terrible
decade of terrorism, and after that, the country
found itself with a terrible housing crisis.
So the Chinese were asked to build 55,000
housing units around Abuja.
You can see some of them here.
And never in the country, the housing blocks
have been so high.
It's like 15 floors, and it's the first time
in the country they built so high housing
units.
Paolo Woods: The Chinese working on government
projects, tend to live in a very isolated
way.
They live in compounds cut off from the local
population.
And they sleep there, are fed there, and this
is their lunch break in one of these such
compounds.
And they will feed the rest of their meal
to the dog, who eventually then they will
kill and eat, which is something which has
created a lot of problems in Algeria, because
this is unimaginable in a Muslim country that
you might eat a dog.
And a lot of misunderstandings and uncomprehension
between the two communities has been growing.
Serge Michel: Here, it's the working site
of the highway they are building.
So you should imagine it's a thousand kilometers
highway, stretching from Morocco to Tunisia
all across Algeria.
And the Chinese had only 14 months to do the
work, because the president wanted the highway
to be finished for the elections.
And to meet the challenge, they had to import
to Algeria about 12,000 Chinese workers, of
which you see just one here on the picture.
Paolo Woods: And here, we're again in one
of these camps where the Chinese live.
It's a very weird place.
I mean, these are prefabricated camps which
are then moved along with the work of the
highway.
It's strange, because they're almost a mix
between a concentration camp and Disneyland.
They're very esthetic, they're very pure,
and even if we had all the government authorizations
-- the Algerian government authorizations
-- to visit them, when we got there, they
tried everything to refuse us to go in, because
they considered this as Chinese territory
like if it was an embassy.
Serge Michel: So now we just move to Angola.
Angola had experienced 27 years of civil war.
The country is at its knees.
And after the war, the country asked the western
agencies and governments, IMF, World Bank,
to organize a donor's conference, but everybody
refused, because the country was lacking democracy
and good governance.
So then Angola turned to the Chinese, and
they came in with about $10 billion in their
suitcases.
And they also moved in a lot of workers -- of
which one is here -- doing a very simple work.
So it's not very high qualified work, just
moving your shovel in the side of the road.
But the Chinese had built that road between
the capital Rwanda and Lobito in the south
in six months, which is very fast.
And it's badly needed.
The country is one of the most heavily mined
countries in the world.
And having safe roads is an essential condition
for the _________.
Paolo Woods: Yes, and it's not only roads
are needed but also railroads.
This is one of the very few stretches of railroad
actually still working in Angola.
And the Chinese have bid and are going to
construct the railroads in the future.
As you see, the ones that exist are in very
bad condition, very short.
And to bring all the produce from the inside
of the country to the coast, railroads and
roads are essential.
And so, in the future the road will be built
by the Chinese.
Serge Michel: You know, this is one of the
railways that is already done by the Chinese.
They are doing three lines, all at different
levels in the country.
And this is very important.
You know we have gone to the center of Angola,
and you had farmers there cultivating carrots
and other vegetables unable to ship them to
the capital cities, so they were not knowing
what to do with their production.
And on the other side, if you are in Rwanda,
the carrots you eat are coming from Brazil
by boat.
So it's at a very expensive price because
you have -- the country's so rich now.
The country that had the record growth rate
last year 27 percent and because of oil, it's
the second oil-producing country now in Africa
after Nigeria.
So everybody is importing stuff there in such
a rich place, and there is a long queue for
boats to unload in the ports of Rwanda.
Paolo Woods: And this is still in Angola.
This is an engineer on his one day of a month
in the warehouse of the company which also
doubles as their sleeping quarters.
You can see that, behind him, the nettings
are covering the bed; and that's where they
sleep.
You have to think that this guy -- he's an
engineer.
He's a qualified engineer, but he works for
something probably less than a thousand dollars
a month setting up antennas for mobile networks.
And these are the living conditions.
He sleeps in the warehouse, he works extremely
hard, very long hours.
And it's very difficult to imagine an American
company or a British company or a French one
would send workers to Africa -- engineers
to Africa -- and live and work in such conditions.
Serge Michel: We just had an interview with
this man's boss in the office just behind
the wall that you see here, and the company
is building hotels in the south of Angola.
Amongst other things, the boss told us that
the relationship between Chinese workers and
local women were forbidden, and that if any
of his men would have been caught, he would
be immediately sent back to China.
But, when we came out, we stumbled on this
night guard with his female companion cooling
off in the African night, and you might notice
that his zipper is open.
Paolo Woods: And here, we go to Zambia, where
Chinese farmers are buying big parts of land
-- cultivatable land, what they're going
to cultivate on -- and they're doing very
well, because the price of food has gone up
so much in the recent years, that, every year,
they buy more land around them.
Serge Michel: Here, the main reason why China
is in Zambia is for the copper.
There is a province called "Copper Belt" full
of mines, and China has bought a few of these
mines.
And you see now here the official meeting
on this smelter.
It is a 300 million project that China is
building, a copper smelter with officials.
And we like the way it is, because it is very
much a souvenir of the sixties when the Chinese
would go to Africa for friendship and cooperation
-- friendship among people and the old cooperation.
At that time they had ideology, and they wanted
to prove that they were the best communists,
better than the USSR.
But now, they don't have any other ideology
other than just business.
Paolo Woods: And they're doing a lot of business.
Like, in this case, this is one of the bosses,
one of the companies standing on some of the
copper that he's extracted.
Copper had shot up in price a lot more than
what oil had a couple of years ago.
And the profits were amazing for the Chinese
companies, but not all is smiles.
The anti-Chinese sentiment in Zambia is growing
very fast.
The Chinese pay very little, do not observe
security regulations, and there have been
big incidents in Zambia, killing a lot of
workers.
Serge Michel: Well, getting access to copper
mines -- Chinese copper mines -- in Zambia
has been tremendously difficult for us.
And they believe that journalists are all
spies or anti-Chinese agents.
So soon after the previous picture of the
boss on his copper, we've been expelled from
the Chinese vicinities, and we were left outside
contemplating the toxic by-products of the
smelting being done in the nature.
Paolo Woods: Here is Vivian and her four-year-old
son, Jonathan.
When Vivian gave birth to Jonathan, she and
her immediate family were pretty astonished
to see Jonathan had Asian features.
And she deeply regretted having had a relationship
with her boss in a Chinese restaurant.
And she was abandoned by her husband as a
consequence.
And Jonathan -- for the time being -- is refused
by both communities, the African community,
the Zambian community, and the Chinese community.
Serge Michel: In this final image of our presentation
here today, you see another case of a child
born from a Zambian mother and a Chinese father.
The father disappeared soon after his birth,
and for the time being, these children are
not well-accepted.
This one is not even allowed to leave the
house where his mother lives, because the
Zambian-Chinese relationship right now are
very tense, because the Chinese are in Africa
to stay.
This will happen, I think, more and more in
the future.
And maybe, one day, these kids will embody
a new Africa.
>> Thank you.
>> [Clapping]
Paolo Woods: If anybody has questions concerning
-- yes.
>> [pause]
>> I actually didn't realize this was the
book I bought in Korea.
I was traveling through, and I saw this book.
It said, "China/Africa," which is, I think,
a direct translation of your original title?
>> Right.
>> And I read like maybe a couple of pages
of the book.
I bought it, just to tell you.
[laughter] Just to make you feel better.
No, I'm just kidding.
And you mention that there was like an interesting
gaze that you had on this particular issue,
because you are French.
Like, could you expound a little more on that?
Paolo Woods: None of us is actually French.
>> Okay.
Paolo Woods: Serge is Swiss, and I am.
>> Sorry, I apologize for that.
Serge Michel: You can guess from my terrible
"Frenchy" accent that, no, I'm Swiss.
But, the fact that I work for French media,
and France had colonies in Africa.
So I mean, we can easily go through some places.
But the thing is that Chinese themselves have
no colonial history in Africa.
So they are not limited to a few countries
where they were the masters before independence.
And, for this strip, we went to former Portuguese,
former British, former French colonies, and
that is very important, because the Chinese
do have 53 countries in Africa where they
are present in.
>> So just as a follow up question, do you
think China will become like sort of a colonial
power in Africa?
Paolo Woods: I think it's --
>> I mean, because the only reason I ask is
like, their relationship with like a couple
of their boundary regions, and also because
you did end the note with, "Look at these
children."
Paolo Woods: Right.
>> So I just want to follow up with that.
Paolo Woods: Well, I have problems with the
word "colonial," because colonial immediately
defines in the minds of the Africans a very
specific period, very specific things.
The Chinese are clearly in Africa to stay,
but the Chinese do not have a colonial past,
and -- differently from the colonial powers
-- they do not come and try to impose their
religion, their philosophy, their way of living.
They're coming for business.
They're very clear, very pragmatic about it.
They want to speak about "win-win" relationship.
As you have seen their presentation, sometimes
it's "win-win," sometimes it's not.
But they do not come with the idea of "We're
colonizing this.
This is going to become a province of China.”
So that is very important that there is a
difference.
But that does not mean that there are a lot
of elements that are not problematic of the
Chinese expansion there.
Serge Michel: For instance, the fact that
they take from Africa raw materials, they
process it in China, and re-export it in Africa
as finished product is a colonial scheme.
And the French, the British, do the same.
So, in this way, Africans must be aware that
they should ask more of the Chinese.
Because, the more Africans will request, the
more they will get from China.
And China is also in the learning process
in Africa.
I mean, there have been mistakes.
Zambia, apparently, is one of the biggest
mistakes.
And they have understood that they have created
an anti-Chinese feeling.
And they are learning quite fast.
So probably, if Africans manage to tell their
Chinese partners to behave better, they will.
You bought it in Chinese?
>> I bought it in Korean.
>> [laughter]
Serge Michel: Okay.
Paolo Woods: We've been very lucky the book
has been translated in ten different languages.
And one of the things I'm particularly proud
about is the fact that it's been translated
in Chinese -- which is not expected, you know.
And a lot of people have felt that maybe there
was an anti-Chinese sentiment in our book.
And I think that our aim to try to be as balanced
as possible is a proof that it's in English,
in French, in Italian, and in lots of languages,
but in Chinese, in mainland China.
>> Hi. Given that a lot of western governments,
corporations aren't investing in Africa as
much because of security concerns or lack
of good governance, do you think they're missing
out somehow on big opportunities for business?
is the first part of the question.
Second part would be, you know, ultimately
do you think this is going to be a good thing
for the continent?
I mean, you have all this money coming in;
surely, the Chinese government doesn't care
about safety as much in some cases.
But do you think like, all this money and
all this interaction will eventually help
the continent grow economically?
Serge Michel: If we start maybe from the second
part, I mean, yes, I think it will help -- not
only because China is actually leaving good
things behind her in Africa like infrastructures.
You know, in the past, the West would buy
or extract African oil, and pay it with money
to local governments, and that would fill
their pockets and never reach the simple people.
China pays in infrastructures, bridge, dams,
railways.
And, that is more useful for common people.
So I think it's good.
And it's also good, because it has awakened
actually the west.
You know, in the 90's, America and Europe
were a bit fed up about Africa.
They had the impression -- especially after
the genocide in Rwanda -- that there was nothing
to be done with Africa.
The more money you pour in Africa, the more
money disappears, and it will never take off
and never develop.
So Chinese went there and are showing to the
western powers that there is something to
be done and there are some good reasons to
go.
And now, you can see -- for example in Angola
-- many countries have wakened up, and are
queuing in at the airport of Rwanda to make
partnership with Angolese people.
So for these reasons, I think it's good.
But, you want to answer the first part of
the question?
Paolo Woods: I forgot what the first part
of the question is.
>> Basically, is the West missing out?
It seems apparent.
Paolo Woods: No, it's coming back fast, the
West.
It definitely has missed out, but at times,
you take like Sudan, you know?
Western companies cannot do business there,
because it's under sanction.
So that was a golden opportunity for China
to go in and go for the Sudanese oil.
For once they were not buying the oil, they
were actually producing the oil, they were
extracting the oil themselves.
The Sinopec Chinese companies were there.
But, more and more, I think what we will see
is that, the West will start looking at Africa
again not only as a place, you know, good
for handouts or good for aid campaigns.
You know, "Poor Africans, let's help them,"
but sees them as a place where you can do
business.
And this will happen if the countries have
more infrastructure.
Obviously, if they have more stable, reliable,
democratic governments.
And Chinese are not pushing for that side.
They're pushing for infrastructure, and they're
pushing for their own interest of raw materials.
But the attention on Africa is going to attract,
again, attention from other countries.
As we have recently seen with your president
going to Ghana.
>> Yeah, it seems like there's going to be
a tension ultimately, because -- whereas the
Chinese government is very lax about safety
or regulations or who they do business with,
and maybe they're willing to pay their workers
pittance.
Paolo Woods: Mm-hmm.
>> It seems like if American corporations
tried to go in there, they wouldn't be able
to compete with that.
There would be a lot of backlash.
They would have to follow a lot more regulations.
And so, it almost -- you have these corporations
which will probably try to do that, but not
really be able to compete with the Chinese.
Serge Michel: Sure.
Paolo Woods: If there's going to be competition,
I mean, Africa was a place for ideological
competition in the 60's and 70's between the
two blocks during the cold war.
And I think now, it's going to become a place
for business competition.
Chinese obviously have an advantage right
now, but western business can bring other
advantages, other accesses, that the Chinese
cannot necessarily bring.
Serge Michel: You know, many countries in
Africa were, after independence, locked in
a close relationship with their former colonial
power.
Like Gabon was locked with France and Brazzaville
as well and Zambia with Britain.
And this was odd, because the former Metropol
like ______ would decide everything which
was going on in Brazzaville or in Neboville,
and Chinese came as competitors to the French
there, and they opened the market.
And they can level.
The African government, if clever, can use
this competition to get better conditions,
both from the French and from the Chinese.
We've seen that in Niger.
There's a chapter in the book where the Niger
government was locked in the relationship
for uranium with the French Areva, which is
one of the world's biggest nuclear companies.
And they were not satisfied with the conditions
the French were giving, so they called the
Chinese in.
They did as if they were ready to give a big
uranium mine to the Chinese, and they pushed
that impression very far.
And then, the French panicked and offered
double price for the yellow cake, and they
signed it.
The Chinese were, in this case, just used
as a.
But it's clever from the Niger countries.
>> Go ahead.
>> [pause]
>> The last few minutes of conversation seems
like focused on Chinese governments, African
governments.
I was actually visiting Saigon Amigos in May,
and anecdotally, I just noticed in some places,
the relationship between individuals and the
government was stronger than in others.
And so, especially in the case of the poor
working conditions that you mentioned, which
by the way, I think is universal -- like Nike
has horrible factories in southeast Asia too.
I don't think China's the only perpetrator.
Who do you think is in the best position to
change that like, the worker's union, or do
you think governments -- African governments
-- will even be motivated to?
Serge Michel: It's very difficult.
I mean, in Africa, cynicism has been a way
to govern and a real -- and a characteristic
of ministers, so.
I don't know.
Nigeria is a good example, because it has
a real market -- inner market -- you know,
150 million people.
It's the largest population in Africa.
And there are elections, almost fair and free.
And it's a country that is much advanced,
and they are also one of the most interesting
places for Chinese.
You have about -- we estimate -- 50,000 Chinese
in Nigeria.
And the plane -- the flight line of Beijing/Lagos
was the first direct air link between China
and Africa two years ago.
So it's a country, like a laboratory, for
these new kinds of settings.
And I think, well, Nigeria has many problems.
Like, it has guerilla in the Niger delta.
It has also some fighters in the north -- Muslim
fighters -- these days very much enraged.
But, I think, it can deliver yeah, better
relationship for workers.
Better working conditions.
Paolo Woods: And at the end, I think that
who is going to make a difference are the
African people, if they live in a country
where the government can be kept accountable,
which is not the case in many places.
If you have a country which is very rich in
resources, and the government money does not
come from taxes but comes from the resources,
the government has no problems being reelected,
because it does not depend on the people.
Instead, if there is a system where the government
is accountable to the people, and there's
really a vote that's going to happen like
it happened in Europe during the Industrial
Revolution, where people then were able to
pass laws that make things respected.
In the photograph I showed of the workers,
who I said was the birth of a union.
Those workers actually paid less than the
country's minimum wage.
So Congo has a minimum wage.
And in a government project being constructed
by Chinese, the minimum wage is not observed.
So that's the whole, you know, absurdity of
it all.
So you often have African countries that have
systems -- rules -- that are not that bad,
but they're not observed by the local power.
And well, this will change through the effort
of the people there.
If that answers your question, I'm not sure.
>> I'm curious.
I spent some time living in African settlements
in East Africa, and there was sort of a rule
of thumb at the time, even back then.
And it was, the French would build the railroads,
and the Chinese would build your highways.
And so this division of labor and the two
competed with each other.
It was all very polite, you know.
Both working on infrastructure, but Chinese
did the highways, French did railroads.
Now, that's changed.
Particularly if Chinese are building railroads.
My question really is, "Are the French still
in the railroad game?
And what -- when -- in the process did the
-- and why did the Chinese beat them at that
game?
Because they really, really wanted to keep
the railroad business, at least back in the
70's.
When did that change?"
Serge Michel: Well, it changed in the 90's
when Chinese came in.
The World Bank has actually eased a lot the
penetration of China in Africa, because they
have imposed tenders for all projects of a
certain amount.
So now, they are bidding companies, and the
Chinese always win because they are cheaper
and they pretend to have the same quality
as the other.
The company doing the railway in Africa is
the one that has built this amazing line in
China between the main center of China and
Tibet that goes over 4,000 meters high tunnels,
you know, they have the technical skills to
do that.
Now, every time there is a tender, the Chinese
outbid the French, and the French have lost
the thing.
The French were not able to send a lot of
workers there.
They would send supervisors, engineers, head
of project, and then they would recruit locally
people.
And that has proved to be more expensive than
the Chinese method, which is sending thousands
of Chinese workers there, and working night
and day.
So this way, yeah.
I think from the 90's on, French has been
out of the railway business.
And I don't know any project done in Africa
-- like a road or railway -- done by a western
company, except Brazil is doing a few roads
in Angola.
>> One other question too, and I came in a
few minutes late, so you might have mentioned
this, because you were talking about dam when
I came in.
But, as I understand it, the Chinese at the
moment basically are going around Africa,
and if there's a river, they'll put a dam
on it.
There are a lot of environmentalists who are
very afraid, because a lot of the places they're
putting dams are going to be flooding wetlands,
which for instance, are the only habitat for
things like hippopotamus or whatever.
And the thought of the tremendous amount of
species, in fact, are going to be threatened
if these dams go in.
Is there any -- this is sort of an odd place
for this sort of thing.
But, can you speak at all to any awareness
of the environmental impact of what's going
on?
Paolo Woods: You have loads of western environmental
NGOs in Africa trying to protect African environment.
Very often, it's as I say it's western and
not African NGOs, because it's difficult if
you are a westerner and there are Africans
living in very simple conditions telling them,
"Look, this is beautiful.
You have a beautiful nature here.
You should not get factories.
You should not get roads.
You should not get dams.
You should not get Blackberries.
You should just live the way you are.
It's so beautiful.
Because I need those photographs for National
Geographic," you know?
And so, I completely understand what you are
saying.
And it's a sentiment that we as westerners
feel when we go there and see what development
can bring in good and in bad.
And today, many of these environmental NGOs
-- their chief enemy is the Chinese companies.
And so, it's extremely important that they're
present, and extremely important that they
keep controlling that -- if there is a development
that is going to take place, can take place
along lines which are possibly a bit sustainable.
Serge Michel: Yeah.
The thing is that the Chinese companies are
not sensitive to public opinion.
If you take any western company like, even
Chevron or the oil companies Texaco, Mobile,
they would somehow feel, I mean, that a good
article in New York times would frighten them
to do a very bad project or a project very
bad for the environment somewhere.
And because they have shareholders, they have
prepress, and everything.
In China, it's not the case at all.
So the companies feel very free to do what
they want.
The thing is that, as for the dam you mentioned,
in Africa there have been about a hundred
sites prepared for dams -- or, not prepared,
but analyzed that were good for dams.
And there is a huge hydropower potential in
Africa, and all the projects Chinese are doing
right now are projects that have never been
financed, but had been prepared and analyzed
before by western agencies.
So it's places where the damage, for the time
being, is limited, because it has been already
studied by the western NGOs and companies.
The only thing is that, in the west, nobody
was ready to finance the projects, so they
were like on hold for decades.
And now, Chinese are just using the same sketches,
and doing them.
Serge Michel: Yes, yes?
>> I have two questions.
You have mentioned that there is a growing
diaspora of African people in China.
So, do you have numbers about how many people
approximately might be immigrating?
And the second question is, you also mentioned
that you didn't want to just read numbers;
you actually wanted to go there and see it
in person.
What do you consider the most value-added
benefit of going there in person as opposed
to just reading numbers and stats?
Serge Michel: Well, the number of Africans
in China is very difficult to say.
But I've seen figures like 10, 20, 30,000
people in the west coast.
And
you have local -- there is a city in China
called Yu, where it's one of the world's biggest
markets.
And you have kilometers of stands to build,
each one sells one product.
And in this place for example, you have two,
three thousand Africans living there on a
permanent basis to ship containers to their
homeland.
And now, you have more and more also students
-- African students -- that are getting grants
to study Chinese in China.
Translators are badly needed.
We witnessed that in Africa.
There is a lack of translators that is not
easing the communication between the two sides.
Paolo Woods: And a lot of African businessmen
are not part of the diaspora in the sense
they don't live in China all the time, but
will go there regularly.
So they will go there, you know, when the
containers are getting ready to then bring
goods to Africa.
And on your other question, "Why is it better
to do on-the-ground reporting than analyze
statistics?" is that, if you analyze statistics,
somebody is doing those statistics, and those
statistics have to be done on the ground in
the first place.
Because otherwise, it's very difficult to
know exactly what is happening.
A lot of things we had read in articles before
we set out to do this book, were misleading,
were wrong, were even racist.
And I think that to make an issue like this
interesting and touch the reader, you cannot
just have analysis.
You have to meet these people.
You have to spend time with them.
And we were spending endless nights in karaoke
bars with Chinese or in casinos.
And that's what, I think, we tried to transmit
in the book that, not only were you seeing
a phenomenon from a statistical point of view,
but also you're seeing it from a human point
of view.
You have to think that Africa and China are
probably two of the most different people
you can imagine.
And they're brought together -- not by an
empathy -- but are brought together by business
needs.
And this collision is a collision will be
very important for what the world is going
to be in the future.
And we wanted to tell this collision from
an on-the-ground reporting aspect.
And we wanted to have text and photographs
to give you an image of what this meant and
what this included.
You know, we have been working in Afghanistan,
in Iraq, in Kosovo, in many war situations.
Just a couple of weeks ago -- one month ago
-- we were in Iran doing the uprising after
the election.
And I think we've never done such a hard assignment
as this one, because getting access to the
Chinese in Africa is very, very difficult.
In Zambia, we spent there over a month, and
the first three weeks, I did not take one
single picture, because I was only trying
to get access.
And it was a door closed, a phone slammed
down all the time.
And I think that's what still makes journalism
interesting and still necessary, especially
in a time where the press is living such a
hard metamorphosis.
[pause]
>> How did you choose the countries that you
visited, and did you consider Tanzania at
all, specifically?
Serge Michel: Well, it was very difficult,
because the Chinese are present in 50 countries
in Africa.
And in every country, they do almost everything.
We wanted to choose countries which, each
time, something specific would be highlighted,
like the forest in Congo, like the highway
in Algeria, like the mines in Zambia.
We thought that every aspect of the story
should be covered -- embodied by one place.
Yeah, we considered Tanzania.
But, as we were in Zambia next door, we thought
it's -- I know there are many Chinese there
as well.
On this East Coast of Africa, southeast coast,
there are many Chinese there that have been
there for a long time, like a century or so.
You know, when slavery was abolished at the
end of the 19th century, the slaves were actually
replaced by coolies, the Chinese labor, and
these coolies were imported massively in Africa
and also as well in America to build the railways,
TransAtlantic.
And you have these communities -- they are
living, but they don't even speak Chinese
anymore.
They are called by Chinese, "The birds without
wings," because they don't speak their own
language.
We were a bit -- we don't want to report on
these people, because they are not a new phenomenon.
They are left from history.
So we wanted to see the newcomers the last
ten years.
And they are mostly in Nigeria, in Angola,
in Zambia.
>> Thank you very much.
>> [Clapping]